and kirst armor leader of the opposition
of the United Kingdom taking his place
on the global stage the leader of the
opposition today was Secure St Thomas
Day at the world economic Forum in Davos
and he came with a message I think
there's a sense here that the UK has
drifted is not part of the global
conversation we want to reverse that and
it's very important that we do because
investment foreign direct investment has
gone down dramatically under this
government I do think the Prime Minister
should have been here I'm very happy to
be here as an ambassador for UK plc
like it or not Davos is where you come
to drum up investment the PM may not be
here but his business secretary was
there are a lot of businesses here
there's a lot of business to be done for
British jobs so not to be here would
literally uh to be saying we don't care
about that investment send it elsewhere
and I think that would be crazy anyone
watching this uh who you know has a job
and wants a a better perhaps better paid
job investment is the way that we win
that and and Britain's Brilliance at it
we need to be here to make sure that we
do lead the world
but while Mr chaps tried to bang that
drum it wasn't resounding as much as
usual one of the long-standing
Traditions here at Davos is that towards
the end of the summit the British
contingent The Business Leaders as they
call themselves meet for a special lunch
in that hotel over there now I cannot
remember another one of these lunches
going back a decade or more which was
quite so somber a lot of people saying
Britain just simply isn't there in the
room at this forum it needs to be doing
more even as the US is spending billions
indeed so far the UK has no response to
the inflation reduction act in which
America is splurging on green investment
so much for building back better the
last thing is stop worrying about
criminology
you know it's difficult to work out
what's going to happen in UK politics
which brings us to this man the xpm was
the other big British name in Davos here
for a panel about Ukraine it's not that
he wanted to stop and talk about it
oh you know tell us
hello even while trying to keep a low
profile Boris Johnson still somehow
eclipsed the government should wish to
not really beat her hello
[Music]
Sky News and Davos